ich habe gute aber auch für mich schlechte
bücher gelesen und trotzdem hat mich jedes
buch beeinflusst inspiriert und wurde teil meiner
gedankengänge wie es bei menschen eben auch ist
du machst gute und schlechte erfahrungen mit
menschen und trotzdem ich sehe ein teil von dir
trotzdem hatte ich haben sich so viele menschen
auch wenn du sie mich macht ist oder so da sie
die reben ja auch was böses angetan haben dich
beeinflusst jeden menschen den doch begegnet weil
es etwas was du nicht weiß hat dinge gelernt
die du vielleicht nie so lernen würde und ich
sage dir hinter jedem buch steckt ein mensch
ein autor ein team vielleicht auch das leben
hat mir die säulen im leben geht es nicht immer
nur um eine sache auch das hatte florian horn zum
beispiel einmal gesagt florian ex milliardär
hat auch diese lektion gelernt die anke er
hier auch gesagt hat mutter etwas was kannst
du meine tochter mitteilen und sie sagt dann
handle und denke immer mit dem herzen ja und das
werden wir heute noch wahnsinnig schwer das fiel
mir früher war es unmöglich für mich war wirklich
ein sehr wissenschaftlich orientierter mensch wie
ich heute auch noch wahnsinnigen wissens begierig
und das blieb hängen das bleibt immer noch hängen
aber jetzt die zu den verstand was bringt er
das geld zu haben was bringt dir das reich zu
sein erfolgreich zu sein in deinem beruf was du
machst aber dann alleine zu sein was bringt das
wenn du ein fettes haus aus nur vettels auto
aber keine richtige familie keine freunde hast
und keine ahnung hast was liebe bedeutet was
bringt dir das im leben gibt es wie gesagt
verschiedene säulen beruf und finanzen familie
freunde gesundheit sinn und kultur was möchte
ich dir jetzt damit sagen lese nicht nur ein
genre das leben bietet mehr als nur ein genre
bücher öffnen die mehr als nur eine tür als ich
angefangen habe bücher zu lesen habe ich nur
sachbücher gelesen und war auch immer so ja nee
ich lese nichts anderes wie alle anderen bücher
sind scheiße ich lese nur sachbücher wo ich das
gefühl habe etwas neues zu lernen mir irgendwas
neues anzueignen und so weiter und so fort aber
dann habe ich angefangen auch romane in die hand
zu nehmen und das ist eine ganz andere welt
und teilweise saß ich da auch und war gerührt
emotional berührt und habe geweint wie sonst
was es geht einfach nur darum zu sagen hinter
ihrem buch steckt ein autor hinter jedem autor
stecken geschichten die du vielleicht so nie
erlebt hättest wo du daraus lernen kannst und
vielleicht ist das eine buch ob es ein roman
ist ein krimi oder was weiß ich das buch was dein
leben für immer und ewig ins positive verändern
menschen schreiben dinge runter die sie gelernt
haben ihre erfahrungen ihre geschichten lektionen
fantasien gedanken und gefühle die sie im jahre
neben angesammelt haben die du in stunden lesen
kannst kreativität fantasie liebe zu literatur
all das darf nicht in vergessenheit geraten
es kommt nicht darauf an wie viele bücher du
in welcher zeit gelesen hast also es gibt ja
genug youtuber die sagen wie du in keine ahnung
wie vielen minuten so viele wörter lesen kannst
oder wie ich ohne büchern einem jahr gelesen habe
aber darum geht es nicht darum geht es nicht wenn
du bücher liest dann geht es nicht immer darum
manchmal ist sogar oder kommt also ein größerer
aufkommen wenn du zwei seiten liest und dann
im endeffekt danach darüber nachdenkt was du
da gelesen hast du gelernt hast wie du das auf
dein leben beziehen kannst bücher in der hand
zu halten rhein zu kritzeln in eine andere
welt hinein zu tauchen wir können in andere
jahre reisen verstehen warum wir menschen
uns so entwickelt haben verstehen warum du
so bist wie du bist in diesem sinne möchte
ich euch meine empfehlungen weitergeben die
mich in den letzten monaten also bücher die
mich in den letzten monaten begleitet haben
und die meine denkweise sehr stark inspiriert
haben beeinflusst haben und auch geändert haben
was bedeutet es zu hoffen was bedeutet die
liebe was bedeutet die liebe in gedanken und
wie meistere ich das leben auch zu schlimmen zu
den schlimmsten zeiten ich zitiere setze mich
wie ein siegel auf dein herz den liebes stark
wie der tod es geht um das buch trotzdem ja
zum leben sagen bei diesem buch habe ich so
geweint ich habe so so geweint das buch hat
victor francke geschrieben victor francke ist ein
psychologe gewesen und war im konzentrationslager
als psychologe in diesem buch beschreibt er oder
teilt er seine erfahrungen die er dort gemacht
hat seine gedanken die er hatte seine gedanken zu
seiner frau seine gedanken zu anderen häftlingen
und schreibt was er beobachtet hat und wie
er trotzdem daraus das größte draus machen
konnte und sein vermächtnis in diesem buch
somit abgegeben hat würde sogar sagen dass
es eine pflicht literatur ist vor allem auch
an all die menschen die sich für geschichte
interessieren aber auch an die menschen die
sich für rührende geschichten interessieren
kennst du das du bist irgendwie so voll
in einer sache drin und vernachlässigt
auf einmal andere dinge und denkst du dir dann
im nachhinein so alter was habe ich da gemacht
und in diesem buch geht es einfach darum sich
auf das wesentliche zu konzentrieren sich auf
das zu konzentrieren was wirklich wichtig im
leben ist es geht um das buch es sozialismus
das habe ich euch auch auf das schön vorgestellt
von greg mit tieren die konsequente suche noch
weniger ein neuer minimalismus der ober die welt
es geht darum das wesentliche vom unwesentlichen
zu unterscheiden und mit disziplin das zu
verfolgen was die eigene größte stärke ist
dieses buch hat mir lektion gelernt die ich
auf alle bereiche meines lebens übertragen
konnte und sei es in beziehungen aber auch
irgendwie produktivität alles und ja auch
sehr einfach zu lesen und ich kann euch das sehr
empfehlen auch der autor ist google coach gewesen
die kunst musik literatur all das sind sachen die
uns menschen wo möglicherweise auch teilweise am
leben halten und das sind sachen wo wir oder wie
wir uns ausdrücken können es geht um das buch
schon work von osten ohne dieses buch hätte
ich auch nicht mit youtube angefangen ohne
dieses buch hätte ich mich gar nicht getraut
meine gedanken zu teilen oder je einfach in
die kamera ein zu sprechen was die posten
hätte ich nervöser gemacht aber dieses buch
inspiriert ein und motiviert ein das zu teilen
was mich bewegt das zu teilen was andere bewegt
und ich weiß gibt es kein es vielleicht noch
selber musik vielleicht malst du selber gerne
aber manchmal vernachlässigt du diese dinge
und vergisst immer wieder was für mehrwert
die ihr diese sachen geben und was er damit auch
einfach sagen möchte ist das was dich berührt was
dich inspiriert was ihren mehrwert gibt kann
auch anderen menschen tausende von menschen
millionen von menschen ein mehrwert geben und
du kannst in der heutigen welt leben verändern
wir werden nie wieder so alt wie in dieser
sekunde die zeit vergeht die zeit holt uns
ein die kindheit holt uns ein wann sind
wir erwachsen es ist das buch vom ende
der einsamkeit von benedict wells ein roman ein
bestseller tools und seine beiden geschwister
wachsen behütet auf bis ihre eltern bei einem
unfall ums leben kommen als erwachsene glauben
sie diesen schicksalsschlag überwunden zu haben
ein roman über das überwinden von verlust in
diesem buch musste ich auch die ein oder andere
träne verdrücken und hat mich auch einfach zum
nachdenken angeregt und mich inspiriert auch
wie ich mit anderen menschen umgehen weil
man nie weiß was andere durchmachen man nie
weiß was in der kindheit sie hatten und ja
jeder kennt jeden und jan chaos und ordnung
und somit auch leiden und leben zwölf rudel
ordnung und struktur in einer chaotischen
welt von jordan wie peterson johnny pedersen
ist auch ein psychologe aus amerika und hat
in harvard und toronto geleert und das buch
ist relativ dick ist hat knapp 600 seiten aber
ist es sehr gut aufgeteilt weil es eben wie der
titel schon sagt in zwölf regeln unterteilt ist
und da geht es grob und ganz einfach darum sein
gleichgewicht zu finden ein gleichgewicht zu
finden für unser leben und er spricht auch
einfach darüber ist dass es naiv wäre zu denken
dass das leben voller glück ist dass das höchste
ziel glücklich sein ist aber das was wir menschen
immer vergessen ist das leiden dazu gehört dass
es naiv ist wenn wir sagen unser leben wird
nur glücklich sein dass in der zukunft wird
das und das passieren es werden immer wieder
schicksalsschläge kommen und es wäre einfach
zu sagen das nie was schlimmes passieren wird
und darum geht's einfach in dem buch darüber
zu sprechen wie gehe ich damit um wie finde ich
mein gleichgewicht wie beziehe ich das auf alle
bereiche meines lebens in diesem sinne bedanke
mich fürs zuhören und schätze das sehr dass du
bist hier hin geschaut hast und vielleicht
dass du auch empfehlungen die du vielleicht
auch teilen möchtest und ich freue mich wenn
du beim nächsten mal wieder mit dabei bist